und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es um die gewinne von
energiekonzernen die preise sind ja
gestiegen man vermutet ja meistens den
ukraine krieg dahinter allerdings gibt
es auch einige informationen die auch
andere gründe anführen greenpeace hat
zum beispiel eine analyse in auftrag
gegeben auf der bei der herauskam dass
alleine im märz in deutschland
mineralölkonzerne zusatzgewinne von 1,2
milliarden euro gemacht haben und
angesichts solcher zahlen hat die
linksfraktion hier einen antrag
eingereicht in dem sie fordert
außerordentliche krisen gewinne von
energiekonzernen abzuschöpfen und möchte
dort eine
extrasteuer eine über gewinn steuer von
25 prozent einführen wenn
energiekonzerne im geschäftsjahr 2022
ihre gewinne um mehr als zehn millionen
euro übersteigen lassen dieser antrag
wird heute hier zum ersten mal
diskutiert das heißt danach kommt er
federführend an den finanzausschuss und
wird danach noch einmal ins plenum
gebracht was auch spannend sein könnte
weil auch die ampelkoalition da durchaus
unterschiedlicher meinung ist aber erst
einmal hören wir die meinung aus der
linksfraktion christian görke sprecher
für finanzpolitik
finanzminister lindner zitiere folgendes
gesagt der ukraine krieg macht uns alle
ärmer zitat ende für die bevölkerung
meine damen und herren stimmt das ohne
zweifel
viele bleiben bei dieser entwicklung auf
den kosten sitzen die vier millionen
armuts rentner in der bundesrepublik
deutschland sogar am meisten und meine
damen und herren das ist eine politische
entscheidung und ebenso ist es auch eine
politische entscheidung das einige
energiekonzerne gerade das geschäft
ihres lebens machen meine damen und
herren allein die europäischen
mineralölkonzerne oder energiekonzerne
haben mehr laut einem bericht der
eu-kommission vom 8 märz
und sie bezieht sich auf einen befund
der europäischen energie agentur eine
zusätzliche gewinn erwartung von 200
milliarden euro in der europäischen
union das ist angesichts dieses
schrecklichen angriffskrieges von putin
eine feststellung wo man sagen kann
nicht alle werden in dieser zeit
herrmann das hat sicherlich mehrere
gründe markt mächtige energiekonzerne
haben zb war einkaufspreise langfristig
gesichert und können dadurch natürlich
einen hohen marktpreis akquirieren und
damit natürlich auch über gewinne hier
abseits ähnlich sieht es aus beim
strommarkt an der strombörse erhalten
alle kraftwerke für ihren strom den
preis die das teuerste kraftwerk
verlangt bei den exorbitanten preisen
die wir da aufgerufen sehen sorgt dieses
prinzip für über gewinne war sogar bei
den günstigsten anbietern über gewinne
sind also all das was zum beispiel die
gewinne der vorjahre übersteigt und auch
hier meine damen und herren erleben wir
eine zeitenwende allein die bilanzzahlen
der europäischen energiekonzerne
offenbarten uns vorüber wie er genau
reden gewinnsteigerungen sie kennen sie
bei
6,6 milliarden oder
146 prozent mehr nach steuern total fina
65 milliarden nach steuern ohne eine
gewinnsteigerung von sage und schreibe
100 87 prozent und deshalb meine damen
und herren muss ein teil dieser über
gewinne endlich abgeschöpft werden und
vor
für die entlastung der menschen auch in
dieser bundesrepublik genutzt und damit
auch weitergegeben werden und das ist
auch gar nicht so spektakulär und er
schaut mal auch in die mitte dieses
konservativen die hammer
österreichischer bundeskanzler
konservativer macht das vor und auch
mario draghi italienischer
ministerpräsident führt gerade da heißt
nicht steuer heißt es abgabe auf über
gewinne ein und hat somit die
energiekonzerne deutlich in die
verantwortung genommen erst mit zehn
prozent und jetzt hat er es erhöht auf
20 prozent so geht man mit den
krisengewinnern nicht so geht man mit
den krisengewinnern um und nicht wie der
bundesfinanzminister meine damen und
herren denn jeden tag hier einen neuen
pappkameraden vorbringt um die summer x
abzusuchen deshalb ein besonderer
hingucker
ein letzter platz vor präsidentin mein
besonderer appell an die grünen und die
spd macht sie den rücken gerade wenn sie
diese dieser abzocke und stimmen sie
unserem antrag zu wenigstens einen
gesetzentwurf vorzulegen nach
italienischem vorbild vielen dank
das wort hat der kollege bernhard
daldrup wir die spd
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
der impuls der hier gesetzt wird mit dem
antrag der ist richtig denn ich glaube
es verstößt irgendwie gegen unser gefühl
von gerechtigkeit und solidarität wenn
extraprofite durchkriegen oder durch
krise sozusagen
erwirtschaftet werden und
zweitens
dass sachsen fast immer es wachsen
trotzdem auf die staatlichen aufgaben in
solchen situationen und ich glaube das
ist auch berechtigt die frage nach der
finanzierbarkeit der leistungsfähigkeit
des staates dann zu stellen und erst
recht wenn man sich einer schuldenbremse
auch noch verpflichtet von daher ist der
impuls gut ich will aber auch sagen ich
erlebe ein kleines déjà vu denn ich hab
zu ziemlich genau diesem antrag vor
einem jahr hier auch gesprochen da hieß
er allerdings außerordentliche krisen
gewinne von energiekonzernen abschöpfen
eine vor einem jahr entschuldigung ließ
derselbe antrag abschöpfung der extra
profite von krisen gewinn wie amazon
also es war im grunde genommen der
gleiche antrag andere überschrift und es
geht auch damals um den über gewinn
steuer allerdings nur für digital
konzerne und jetzt ist der alte antrag
gewissermaßen aufgesucht worden so ein
bisschen copy & case und es ist
gewissermaßen das eine wort durch andere
ersetzt worden und da muss ich sagen das
ist ein meiner meinung nach ziemlich
unglückliches vorgehen weil es schadet
eigentlich derjenige denjenigen die so
eine gewisse sympathie für dieses
konzept der über gewinn steuer haben
wenn man es so von fall zu fall
da muss ja jeder sorge haben trotz der
wirklich wirtschaftlich erfolgreich ist
booms droht einsetzen so etwas also es
ist eine schwierige geschichte weil ich
habe ja ich habe denn mich durchaus eine
sympathie zu dass dazu aber ich will
sagen es gibt eine reihe von
abgrenzungsproblemen die berücksichtigt
werden müssen das hat auch das gutachten
des wissenschaftlichen dienstes jahr
gezeigt die gründe für die entstehung
eines über gewinns können ganz
unterschiedlich sein sie können
sozusagen einfach nur ohne eigene
leistung
erzielt werden sie können aufgrund von
innovationen erzielt werden und es gibt
probleme mit referenzwerten mit
verrechnungen beispielsweise das ist
eine spezial debatte die wir
wahrscheinlich jetzt hier an dieser
stelle schon aus zeitgründen nicht
führen können also das sollten wir
fortsetzen aber was ist denn alternativ
jetzt zu tun zum glück ist es ja auch
heute schon so dass höhere gewinne
zunächst mal höhere steuerzahlungen von
unternehmen nach sich ziehen ich habe
schon
praktisches beispiel die stadt mainz
beispielsweise ihre schulden hohe
verschuldung gewissermaßen durch
exorbitant gestiegene
gewerbesteuerzahlungen hat ausgleichen
können das ist sicherlich gut aber wir
haben trotzdem noch ein zusätzliches
problem nämlich bei der gestaltung von
steuerschlupflöchern wenn ich jetzt mal
so sagen darf und bei der
internationalen gestaltungen die
mindestbesteuerung auf internationaler
ebene ist deswegen gegen auch
multinational agierende digital konzerne
auch ein richtiger und wichtiger schritt
ich will
auch darauf hinweisen dass wir im
koalitionsvertrag natürlich bestimmte
punkte festgelegt haben zb die
steuerlichen subventionen im
energiebereich gründlich zu überprüfen
und tatsächlich auch in frage zu stellen
ich glaube nämlich dass auch gerade in
diesem bereich energiekonzerne in
erheblichem maße von
steuerbegünstigungen profitieren es ist
meiner meinung nach richtig dass wir als
spd
der letzten großen koalition auf dem
druck standgehalten haben auch den druck
der union stand gehalten haben und den
sogenannten energie spitzenausgleich
nicht pauschal und ungeprüft auf alle
branchen verlängert haben also es sind
immerhin über 9.000 unternehmen und da
sind auch viele aus dem energiebereich
dabei für unternehmen des produzierenden
gewerbes die im internationalen
wettbewerb stehen und gerade in der
jetzigen situation entlastungen
benötigen sind solche solche
entlastungen und solche ausnahmen und
solche unterstützungen auch angebracht
aber reine mitnahmeeffekte für konzerne
die überhaupt kein kabel nikitsch risiko
unterliegen die müssen wir einfach
beseitigen das system der
steuerbegünstigung mehr energie und
stromsektor das ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß
und bedarf eine art überprüfung ich
glaube insgesamt müssen wir zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt drei dinge
machen erstens die wir diversifizierung
unserer energieversorgung unserer
energiequellen dass wir fast in jeder
sitzung konnte jeder rede betont das
muss ich nicht weiter thematisieren
zweitens entlastung unserer bürgerinnen
und bürger diese begründung ist ja auch
gerade vom kollegen
vom kollegen werke angesprochen wurden
bis hin zur abschaffung der eeg umlage
sind die pakete 35 milliarden ich sage
das immer wieder weil man das nicht
geringschätzen will und drittens
stärkung auf des wettbewerbs und
deswegen ist das richtig kartell und
wettbewerbsrechtliche maßnahmen
durchzuführen dass die märkte
funktionieren es ist richtig dass wir
die voraussetzungen im regal top sie
können weil die gleichen schnell oder
langsam sie tun es aber inzwischen auf
kosten in ihrer kolleg das werde ich
jetzt lassen deswegen müssen wir auch
das gwb noch kurz hinweisen und deswegen
bin ich der auffassung ist die spezial
debatte weiter zu führen und ich hoffe
dass wir das konstruktiv nur gucken
dankeschön
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun dr
michael meister das wurden
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die linksfraktion herberger hat
hier einen antrag vorgelegt über
gewinnen steuer auf krisengewinner von
energieunternehmen einzuführen das folgt
dem punkt gedanken dass man umverteilen
soll in diesem land und heideldruck hat
eben von sympathien gesprochen ich habe
sympathien für die soziale
marktwirtschaft
und die soziale marktwirtschaft hat
nicht dem grundgedanken umverteilung
sondern die soziale marktwirtschaft hat
den gedanken
freiheit eigentum wettbewerb
solidarität und subsidiarität und für
diese für diese grundsätze habe ich sehr
viel sympathie und diese grundsätze
haben unserem land in den vergangenen 70
jahren den wohlstand beschert den wir
heute haben und den sollte man nicht
zerstören
zweitens alle gewinne in diesem land
werden besteuert gemäss der
bemessungsgrundlage also auch das was
sie als über gewinde steuer besteuerung
wollen das wird bereits besteuert nach
den regeln die wir haben und was sie
fordern ist eine zweite besteuerung und
dann finde ich ganz toll sie sagen
unternehmen mit hohen gewinnen die haben
ja schon einer großen anteil zum
steueraufkommen beigetragen sollen das
noch mal zahlen und zwar dann wenn sie
zehn millionen mehr ertrag haben als im
vorjahr jetzt nehmen sie mal ein kleines
start-up was gerade aus der verlustzone
kommt jetzt in die gewinnzone gekommen
ist sie zehn millionen überspringt die
zahlen dann ihre über gewinn steuer und
der milliardenkonzern er es geschafft
hat milliarden an ertrag zu
erwirtschaften aber ungefähr auf
demselben niveau wie im vorjahr der
zahlen wir über gewinn steuer nicht ist
doch absoluter blödsinn was ich hier
vorschlagen für eine bestrafen und die
großen müssen der zahl eigentlich habe
ich von emas unglück werde gehört sie
wollen an die großen ran
und deshalb ist jetzt eine absolute
ungleichbehandlung von gewinnen es hängt
nämlich nicht vom gewinn um entstehen
des gewinnes ab sondern vom vorjahr was
eigentlich überhaupt nichts mit der
sache zu tun hat und dann setzen wir
vollkommen falsch an 13 unserer
marktwirtschaft wir haben
bundeswirtschaftsminister frau partner
der momentan der die welt reist und
versucht knappe güter die sich aufgrund
des angriffskriegs russland auf ukraine
verknappt haben hier nach deutschland zu
holen schnell mal gas man könnte die
liste weiter führen und jetzt sagen wir
gleichzeitig diejenigen die aus der
stadt liefern die wollen wir besonders
hoch besteuern glauben sie dass das der
mann habe bei seiner reise hilft wenn er
durch die welt fährt das hierher zu
bringen nein wir werden zu einer
verknappung bei wagen mit der idee von
eh schon knappen gütern und das ist
nicht im interesse unseres landes und
der menschen die hier leben und
an jeder kollege druck sie haben eben
mainz angesprochen mainz ist eine tolle
geschichte piontek
einerseits für uns alle nicht wegen
steueraufkommen sondern wir weil man im
stoff abend das ist genauso unklar ab
was plötzlich nach oben geschossen ist
und dann wird sie schließen über gewinnt
produziert nicht im energiebereich aber
sagen wie es mir momentan nicht der
entscheidende punkt ist doch was sie mit
ihrer über gewinn steuer ton ist in
diesem land innovation bestrafen der der
innovativ ist wird von ihnen bestraft
und wir müssen innovation belohnen und
nicht bestrafen in diesem land
liebe freunde
sie haben die abgrenzungsprobleme
was ist eigentlich ein über gewinnen sie
machen sie es leicht und sagen wenn es
zehn millionen mehr als im vorjahr aus
meiner sinn meiner sicht ziemlich
unsinnige definition dann reden sie von
krisenbedingt wo wird denn in der
definition abgefragt als krisenbedingt
ist oder auch andere gründe hat
und es ist ganz klar wir haben global
steuerberater in diesem land die werden
natürlich dann dafür sorgen dass bei der
frage von rückstellungen bilden bei der
frage wann man gewinne entstehen lässt
dafür gesorgt wird dass man innerhalb
der gewissen schwankungsbreiten bleibt
und die steuer nicht sein also anreiz
für steuergestaltung und ich bin der
meinung wir sollten unsere innovation
auf das geschäft und nicht auf die frage
steuergestaltungen richten und zum
abschluss der hinweis ich sagen naja die
vereinigten staaten von amerika haben
das ja auch schon vereinigten staaten
von amerika hatten genau zwei mal mit
ner gewinnsteuern
erste recht bringt also eingetreten sind
zwei der rechtlich und die begründung
war um die hohen kosten der kriege zu
finanzieren
führen seine über gewinn steuer an
nun sage ich mal schauen sie mal aktuell
die steuerschätzung von vergangener
woche für die bundesrepublik deutschland
und
in unserer steuerschätzung bis 2026
220 milliarden mehr aufkommen als seit
wertgeschätzt haben wir denn eine
situation wo wir uhr kriegskosten und
auch bedingt dadurch steuerausfälle
gegenzufinanzieren haben ich sage nein
und deshalb ist auch der vergleich
stehen sie hierzu usa ziehen vollkommen
fehl am platz wir werden diesen antrag
nicht zustimmen bilder
michael meister war dass der
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck hat
einen so genannten abschöpfung von über
gewinn auch schon in die diskussion
gebracht und seine parteifreundin
katharina weg die wird jetzt hier im
plenarsaal dazu sprechen sie sprecherin
für finanzen der fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und liebe gäste hier im haus
vielen dank für diesen antrag sehr hohe
gewinne von mineral und energiefirmen
sind sie schon seit einigen wochen im
gespräch und die regierung prüft diese
aktuell auch katar und wir sind auch im
gespräch auf eine besteuerung sinnvoll
sein könnte und ich möchte in dieser
erhitzte debatte etwas besonnenheit und
reflexion reinbringen
beginnen möchte ich mit meiner
wertschätzung ehrlichen wertschätzung
für die soziale marktwirtschaft
die uns den wohlstand beschert hat den
wir heute alle wertschätzen es ist klar
wir müssen sie jetzt zur sozial
ökologischen marktwirtschaft
weiterentwickeln denn die kleine tannen
grenzen sind einfach fakt und ohne ihren
respekt und ziehen wir uns eh jeder
grundlage des wirtschaftens im kern
steckt hier aber weiterhin das wort
marktwirtschaft gute funktionierende
märkte haben viele marktteilnehmer denn
sie ermöglichen freien warenaustausch
innovationen ideengenerierung im
endeffekt freude am experimentieren und
zukunftsgestaltung und damit sie
funktionieren brauchen sie ein paar
rahmenbedingungen die verhindern dass es
allzu ernst zugeht sondern eben das
wettbewerb aber in fairer maße möglich
ist umsätze
umsätze und gewinne gehören ganz
natürlich zu dieser marktwirtschaft das
können wir ganz entspannt festhalten als
unternehmerinnen und gründerinnen ist
mir dieser punkt wirklich wichtig
umsätze und gewinne dürfen und soll
natürlich positiv ausfallen wer würde es
der bäckerei oder der buchhandlung oder
der metzgerei um die ecke nicht gönnen
und auf skalieren de kleine und große
unternehmen sollen und dürfen das in
unserer marktwirtschaft das sind ja
gerade die innovativen kräfte die
ressourcen goutieren die wir auch für
die zukunftsfähigkeit unseres kontinents
brauchen
und gute märkte regeln auch einen guten
preis ein marktpreis der daneben
zwischen angebot und nachfrage ein
ökonomisches optimum schafft was wir
jedoch aktuell an den tankstellen und
auf den stromrechnungen sehen ist alles
andere als optimal vielmehr haben wir in
mineral bereich
oligopolistischen marktstrukturen das
ist auch unumstritten überall solche
strukturen verhindern aber die
eigentlich positive kraft von märkten
diese dysfunktionalen märkte sind dann
nicht mehr frei oder sehr im sinne der
marktwirtschaft denn einige wenige
unternehmen können ihre marktmacht
ausnutzen und überzogene preise
durchsetzen und genau das beobachten wir
gerade sehr wahrscheinlich im ölbereich
beispielen diese während der rohölpreis
im märz aufgrund des ukraine kriegs um
zirka 20 cent pro liter gegenüber dem
januar angestiegen war wurden die preise
an den tankstellen um durchschnittlich
circa 48 cent erhöht also zweieinhalb
mal so viel und diese differenz leid
das ist einfach fakt dann nach jetzigem
kenntnisstand komplett als zustand
zusätzlicher gewinn bei den unternehmen
und summiert sich für diese und benzin
zusammen allein für den monat märz auf
circa 1,2 milliarden euro
sind das denn auch über gewinne das muss
man sich ehrlich fragen das ist
entscheidend nach allem was wir jetzt
wissen sind die kostenstrukturen im
wesentlichen ähnlich geblieben die
risiko strukturen sind aber angestiegen
das heißt einen aufschlag zu nehmendes
durchaus legitim aber so hoch
zweieinhalb mal so viel selbst wenn wir
sagen wir mal das ist in normalen zeiten
10% risikoaufschlag ist okay dann werden
wir die restlichen 90 prozent dann doch
über gewinne also etwas mehr als eine
milliarde und dass man in einem monat
zwar sind in deutschen gesellschaften
keine details vor zahlen vorhanden aber
die internationalen zahlen belegen dass
leider auch strukturell und ähnlich
sieht es nicht nur im inneren sondern
auch im energiebereich aus und das auch
in deutschland bei denen die
börsennotiert sind
der markt der freien preisbildung ist im
energiebereich gestört er funktioniert
nicht und das muss man in dieser
deutlichkeit leider sagen und wichtig
ist da auch der gesellschaftliche
kontext dann wären wir auf der einen
seite starke über gewinne offensichtlich
sehr wahrscheinlich dass wird auch
gerade geprüft für einige wenige
unternehmen sehen scheinen die
preissteigerung der energieunternehmen
die inflation kräftig anzuheizen wir
haben ja schon letzte woche und auch
gestern wieder ausführlich über die
inflation gesprochen aber es bleibt
einfach ein riesenproblem wenn die
verbraucherpreise derartig durch die
decke gehen ganz besonders zeigt sich
dass bei den lebensmitteln die über
lieferketten reden wir immer aber auch
sehr stark an den energiekosten hängen
und das interessiert jetzt glaube ich
einige hier in dieser runde
laut dem deutschen brauer-bund droht
jetzt sogar ein mangel an flaschen hier
im sommer weil sich viele brauereien die
erhöhten kosten aufgrund der
energieintensiven flaschen produktion
nicht mehr leisten können klar ist
dieser markt missbrauch von marktmacht
und das entstehen von dysfunktionalen
merken muss verhindert werden nicht nur
wegen des flaschenwurfes
wenn einzelne über gebühr profitieren
und der markt einen angemessenen
ausgleich nicht regelt dann muss der
staat ich nutze ich ja mal einen
veralteten begriff sozusagen als
nachtwächter eingreifen
ausgleichen gehört zu seinen aufgaben
und auch andere europäische länder wie
italien oder griechenland sowie auch die
oecd befürworten die idee der
sogenannten wind folgt of attack station
deswegen müssen wir diese frage weiter
miteinander diskutieren aber eher als
instrument einer kartellrechtlichen
marktkontrolle und so würde die über
gewinnsteuern wenn wir sie denn so
nennen wollen nicht nur zur gerechten
umverteilung und einer entlastung des
haushalts beitragen sondern hätte
gleichzeitig eine wichtige signalwirkung
richtung zukunft überzogene marktmacht
und bis funktionale märkte und deren
effekte sind nicht frei allein durch die
präsenz einer solchen steuer womöglich
würden preissteigerungen die die sie
heute in der die wirtschaft erleben in
zukunft womöglich gar nicht mehr
zustande kommen wegen des signals das
könnte ein wirklich wirksamer und
vorausschauender inflationsschutz sein
wie ich finde lassen sie uns das
gemeinsam weiter besprechen ich freue
mich darauf vielen dank
die energiepreise die gestiegenen
energiepreise sind hier im bundestag ja
schon häufiger thema gewesen und diesmal
ist ein antrag der linksfraktion grund
für diese debatte ihren fans ihr schmidt
spricht jetzt für die ard
dann musterbeispiel von unkenntnis und
der umkehrung von ursache und wirkung
lassen sie mich kurz zusammenfassen was
sie warum fordern und ihnen dann in der
nötigen einfachheit erklären warum das
unsinn ist der ganze antrag fußt auf dem
sogenannten mehrere order prinzip sie
schreiben dass dieses system dafür sorgt
dass alle kraftwerke ihren strom zu dem
preis verkaufen können denen das
teuerste kraftwerk verlangt völlig zu
recht würde jeder dieses system als
ungerecht und ausbeuterisch empfinden so
wie sie ist offensichtlich auch tun
allerdings unter schlagen sie ein
wichtiges detail was dieses marktmodell
überhaupt das wirtschaftlich sinnvoll
werden lässt nicht jedes kraftwerk kann
seinen strom zu dem preis verkaufen
denen der teuerste anbieter verlangt
jedes kraftwerk kann seinen strom zu dem
preis verkaufen denen der teuerste zur
deckung des energiebedarfs benötigte
anbieter verlangt das ist ein gewaltiger
unterschied vereinfacht gesagt verlangt
kraftwerk beispielsweise ein windpark
150 euro und kraftwerk 160 euro pro
megawattstunde wenn nun gerade kein wind
weht genügt die energie nicht mehr und
den bedarf zu decken es muss daher ein
drittes kraftwerk hinzugezogen werden
das vielleicht deutlich teurer ist so
verlangt kraftwerk c ein gaskraftwerk
200 euro pro megawattstunde diese 200
euro hätten dann nach dem merit order
prinzip als strompreis an der börse was
ist hier also wirklich das problem es
gibt gleich mehrere knackpunkte die sie
ideologisch geblendet natürlich
vollkommen außer acht gelassen haben zum
einen haben wir die sehr hohen gaspreise
für amerikanisches trading gas dass die
bundesregierung dem gas aus russland vor
zieht durch die gäste durch die
gestiegenen preise kann das gaskraftwerk
seinen strom nicht günstiger produzieren
und ist so gezwungenermaßen der teuerste
anbieter zweitens wird in deutschland im
zuge der gescheiterten energiewende
nicht ausreichend strom produziert um
den bedarf zuverlässig zu decken gerade
wenn es dunkel oder windstille ist sind
wir nach wie vor auf grundlastfähige
energieformen die kohle gas oder
kernenergie angewiesen da sie viele
dieser kraftwerke abgebaut haben müssen
wir immer wieder teuren strom aus
anderen energiewende freien ländern dazu
kaufen auch das treibt die preise nach
oben
ihre lösung dieses problem ist so
falschen kurzsichtig routiniert greifen
sie zum sozialistischen standard
werkzeug um fordern die abschöpfung von
gewinnen der künftig als
energieunternehmer außerordentliche
gewinne einfährt soll ihrer ansicht nach
mit strafsteuern belegt werden besser
wäre es aber wenn sie die wahren
ursachen für die katastrophale
energiepreis benennen würden das sind
die durch die niedrigzins politik der
ezb ausgelöst inflation der vorzug für
um ein vielfaches und umweltschädliches
fracking gas aus den usa die enormen
untragbaren und immer noch steigenden
steuern auf energie und die unerhörte
bepreisung von co2 im zuge ihres kampfes
gegen das wäre doch
diese gründe werden in zukunft dafür
sorgen dass kraftstoff heizen und strom
für den einfachen bürger
unerschwinglichen flächendeckende
stromausfälle sogenannten blackouts
werden nicht ohne grund vom bundesamt
für bevölkerungsschutz als
wahrscheinlichstes katastrophenszenario
aufgeführt die abkehr von vernünftigen
lösungen zur energieversorgung hin zu
realitätsfernen irving wird noch folgen
haben die sie gar nicht überblicken
können steuererhöhungen oder da
fantasievolle steuer neuschöpfungen sind
genau der falsche weg vielleicht sollten
sie sich gedanken und konkrete und
wirkungsvolle lösungen machen solange
sie noch als parlamentarischer rand
erscheinung hier im hause vertreten sind
vielen dank
[Applaus]
wir haben hier schon viele
finanzpolitiker
gehört für die fdp-fraktion spielt jetzt
der finanzpolitische sprecher der
fraktion markus herbrand
kollegen so genannte über gewinne zu
besteuern das ist die idee mit denen die
linke heute vermeintliche einnahme
probleme unseres staates lösen und
zeitgleich ihre ideen von moral zum
gegenstand unserer steuergesetzgebung
machen möchte im grunde genommen gegen
die vorschläge damit auch in
konsistenter reihe mit anderen
vorschlägen vermögenssteuer
solidaritätszuschlag und
steuererhöhungen für besserverdienende
vermögensabgabe reichensteuer und jetzt
natürlich die über gewinnen steuer
die idee vermeintliche profiteur
profiteure von krisen mehr zur kasse zu
bitten als andere ist natürlich weder
neu noch ist es eine idee die nur den
linken überlegenswert erscheint welche
vorschläge haben wir unlängst von der
eu-kommission vernommen italien hat
entsprechendes verabschiedet darauf
verwiesen worden und auch die
geschätzten kollegen der grünen haben
zumindest mal in person ihrer
parteivorsitzenden das thema unlängst
auf die politische agenda gebracht
da wir ja gut zusammenarbeiten und nicht
noch nicht fusioniert sind können wir
doch darüber debattieren meine ich
lassen wir also die argumente abwägen
es sich bei dieser idee wirklich um ein
sinnvolles instrument oder eher um eine
schnapsidee um das ergebnis
vorwegzunehmen
wir den lehrern dazur schnapsidee
ich will drei punkte nennen die wirklich
dagegen sprechen diese idee ernsthaft
weiter zu verfolgen und wer ehrlich
erster punkt wer ehrlich mit der frage
und unvoreingenommen mit der frage
umgeht wird einiges nicht beantworten
können was ist überhaupt einen über
gewinn kollege meister hat auch schon
darauf ist darauf schon eingegangen
welcher teil eines gewinns ist
eigentlich der krisen begründete gewinn
und woran ist ein krisengewinner
überhaupt zu erkennen an wen adressieren
wir denn überhaupt diese überlegen ist
ich befürchte ich befürchte sie
unterscheiden dann auch nochmal zwischen
guten und bösen krisengewinnern
energiekonzerne und am ehesten dürften
vermutlich böse sein und wird irgend
besteuert war herstellern von masken und
impfstoffen bin ich mir nicht ganz so
sicher und bei den anbietern
regenerativer energien würden sie
vermutlich nicht von krisengewinnern
sprechen und auf die über
gewinnbesteuerung verzichten und ihn
auch in italien im übrigen ist es ja gar
keine gewinnsteuern ist eigentlich einen
mehr an umsatzsteuer die das eingenommen
wird im kern ist also die frage zu
beantworten ist es praktisch überhaupt
umsetzbar was moralisch möglicherweise
so gut klingt und dazu ein klares nein
und jedenfalls ist es keine frage für
das steuerrecht wenn überhaupt die
kollegin ist darauf eingegangen ist es
eher eine frage für das kartellrecht
zweiter punkt es wird man sparte
eindruck erweckt als wenn wir hier in
deutschland nicht schließen gewinner
nicht ohnehin schon besteuert würden ja
also unser steuersystem besteuert diese
gewinne mit knapp 50 prozent um
deutschland hat bereits jetzt mit seinen
hohen steuern und auch mit seiner
immensen bürokratie einen unbestrittenen
standort nachteil im vergleich mit
anderen industrienationen da müssen wir
nicht unbedingt noch draufsatteln
dritter punkt der eigentliche antrieb
für eine solche steuer ist zweifelsfrei
ein insbesondere in zeiten von krisen
aufkommendes gerechtigkeitsempfinden mit
einem solchen eingriff allerdings würden
wir tatsächlich an die wurzel der
funktionalität der marktwirtschaft
herangehen und was bestimmt dass das
stimmt schon sehr nachdenklich wenn ich
bedenke wer hier alle sympathien dafür
hegt die marktwirtschaft funktioniert
über anreizsysteme auch da hat er ist
der kollege meister schon drauf an
eingegangen anreizsysteme dafür waren
und dienstleistungen anbieten zu können
die die gesellschaft dringend benötigt
und anreize dafür das unternehmen quasi
rund um die uhr dafür arbeiten und auch
unternehmen unternehmerische risiken
eingehen und zwar am ende damit die
ganze gesellschaft davon profitiert
dabei müssen wir aushalten das
unternehmen die mit atemschutzmasken
impfstoffen und sia leider auch mit
rüstungsgütern und fossilen energien
geschäfte machen mehr verdienen genau
diese anreizen zu besteuern kann das
gegenteil dessen zur folge haben was man
eigentlich erreichen möchte nämlich am
ende keinen erfolg in der sache und
weniger
staatseinnahmen das ist im übrigen das
kann ich mir nicht verkneifen bei der
wohnungsbaupolitik das gleiche sehr
geehrte damen und herren die befürworter
solcher überlegungen wollen nach meinem
dafür eigentlich ein anderes
wirtschaftsmodell man will nicht
besteuern will er in eicken dafür dafür
spricht immer spricht im übrigen auch
der wortlaut aus dem antrat abschöpfen
wir lehnen diesen antrag aus voller
überzeugung ab
soweit die meinung der fdp fraktion im
deutschen bundestag
auch finanzminister christian lindner
hat sich von einer idee zu einer über
gewinn steuer schon distanziert
vielen dank dafür dass in meinem
vornamen wir richtig ausgesprochen haben
aber sehr gut an vielen dank liebe
kollegen kollegen sehr geehrte damen und
herren
vielen dank liebe kollegin kollegen der
linksfraktion für diesen antrag zu
sprechen damit eine thematik die uns in
den letzten wochen und monate
beschäftigt hat die aber auch in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung sehr heftig
diskutiert wird wir haben doch die
folgende situation dass wir erst mit der
pandemie und dann noch mit dem
russischen angriffskriegen die ukraine
viele herausforderungen haben wo
menschen tagtäglich damit zu kämpfen
haben die merken dass in den
supermärkten die merken das an der
tanksäule
aber auch wir als stadt haben darauf als
reaktion fiel verschiedene maßnahmen
vielen verschiedenen über
fiskalpolitische maßnahmen auf den weg
gebracht um menschen zu entlasten um
menschen zu unterstützen
zeitgleich haben wir aber auch die
situation dass einige einige unternehmen
den letzten jahren gewinne gemacht hohe
dividende ausgezahlt haben und auch
aktienrückkaufprogramme gestartet haben
und da erscheint sich zumindest auf den
ersten blick
zu ergeben und deswegen finde ich den
antrag durchaus gut um darüber zu
diskutieren
mit dem antrag wollen wir das ziel
verfolgen auf der einen seite zusätzlich
der einnahmen zu generieren weil wir als
stadt auch gerade in so einer situation
sind auf der anderen seite und das sehe
ich auch als thema nämlich das
gerechtigkeitsempfinden hier auch
anzugehen das ist nämlich nicht normal
fühlt sich nicht normal an dass so eine
kriegssituation
unternehmen hier so hohe gewinne
erzielen können deswegen deswegen habe
ich durchaus sympathien für den antrag
finde aber dennoch in der das wir als
finanzpolitikerin und finanzpolitiker
diskutieren dann müssen wir schon auch
die spannungsfelder hinweisen und ich
persönlich will auf zwei spannungsfelder
eingehen erstens die frage des
steuersubjekt das als welche unternehmen
wollen wir denn überhaupt besteuern in
ihrem antrag ist die rede von
energiekonzerne und da stellt sich für
mich die frage warum eigentlich nur
energiekonzerne wenn man das sich
anschaut dann sieht man doch moment
waren sie noch lieber kollege wenn man
sich das anschaut dann sieht man auch
tatsächlich dass die rüstungsindustrie
gewinne macht dann sieht man auch das
digitale unternehmen gewinne machen ich
finde persönlich dass wir hier ein
problem der verhältnismäßigkeit haben
und würde das auch in frage stellen ob
das überhaupt
verfassungsrechtlich so einfach möglich
ist zu sagen dass man mut die energie
konzerne hier besteuert dass man sich
nur eine branche heraus greift das wir
nicht fährt das ist nicht richtig und
deswegen finde ich ihren vorschlag hier
nicht sinnvoll die zweite frage ist die
frage der steuer objekten nehme ich die
bemessungsgrundlage und da kann man auch
mit wissenschaftlichen wissenschaftliche
abhandlungen darüber schreiben da kann
man sicherlich tagen und nach darüber
diskutieren es gibt die möglichkeit dass
man sich nur die gewinne im jahr
anschaut das heißt im jahr 2022
beispielsweise oder man schaut sich die
gewinne und vergleicht es mit intimität
in den vorjahren erzielt wurden das ist
das was sie vorschlagen und da wäre
meine frage eigentlich brauchen zehn
jahre warum nicht fünf warum nicht 20
und was ist denn eigentlich ein
überwinden was ist normal gewinnen was
ist ein übergewicht der kollege hermann
ist drauf eingegangen ich finde das ist
nicht etwas was die politik bestimmen
sollte und deswegen persönlich
befürworte ich auch nicht das was sie
gesagt haben und der dritte punkt und
damit komme ich auch bei zum flüssige
vor präsidentin ist die frage dass wir
ja keine erfahrungswerte hier haben wir
können natürlich auch das verweisen was
jetzt in italien passiert ist wir können
auch das erweisen was in den 80ern den
usa passiert wurden gemacht wurde arbeit
tatsächlich tatsächlich für die jetzige
situation gibt es keine erfahrungswerte
und das macht es aus meiner sicht noch
schwieriger hier genau zu sagen wie so
eine maßnahme wie so eine über
gewinnsteuer sich auswirken würde ich
finde das gut dass die diskussion führen
würde mich freuen weiterhin auch diese
diskussion auch hier im hause zu führen
nach jetzigem kenntnisstand sagen wir
das in diesen antrag ablehnen vielen
dank dafür und schon zwei nachmittagen
damit kommen wir zum vorletzten redner
in dieser debatte zu krisen gewinnen und
das ist alois rainer für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
vorsitzender des finanzausschusses
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wie wir
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
ich empfinde die debatte schon als sehr
spannend fallen die reaktionen die ich
aus den regierungsparteien so gehört
habe man könnte durchaus dem antrag was
gutes
abgewinnen
da nur mal weniger gutes abgewinnen ich
bin gespannt wie sich die diskussion war
ihnen dahingehend weiterentwickelt ich
will ihnen vielleicht ein paar gedanken
mit auf den weg geben vor allem für
diejenigen die den antrag befördern
können sie lösen das problem nicht zu
lösen das problem nicht sondern sie
planen es am ende der tage nur auf denn
was glauben sie denn wenn unternehmen
mehr steuern bezahlen mehr steuern
bezahlen müssen was am ende der tage
passiert das wird wieder oben
draufgelegt und am ende der tage
bezahlen es bietet die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher nehmen sie die spitze in
ihre diskussionen mit den das wollen wir
alle nicht gestern haben wurde in diesem
hohen heraus beschlossen die senkung der
energie steuer für drei monate
hier wird erwartet dass sich die
preissituation dann etwas entspannt wenn
wir jetzt auf der anderen seite den
druck durch einige zusätzliche
besteuerung wieder erhöhen würde dann
verpufft dieser effekt wir ein tropfen
auf dem heißen stein deshalb überlegen
sie sich gut was hier am ende der tage
auf
hier machen und nicht zuletzt es ist
auch schon angesprochen worden erscheint
es mir schwierig das ganze zu gestalten
wie gewinnanteile krieg zusammenhängen
dann auch von anderen
wirtschaftsbereichen abzugrenzen das
wurde schon gesprochen italien geht den
weg der über gewinn steuer jetzt muss
man auch einmal feststellen italien oder
andere steuersystem als wir die betriebe
werden generell nicht so hoch besteuert
wie bei uns wir haben haben wir anderes
abgabensystem bei uns gibt es zusätzlich
noch die gewerbesteuer dazu das
verrechnen dann auch im finanzausgleich
im länderfinanzausgleich der konversion
am ende der tage viel spaß dabei sie
werden es nicht schaffen und in die
geschichte komme auch mal gehen erstmal
vorhin schon gegangen am jähriger hat es
auch großbritannien auf frankreich in
den jahren 15 und 21 um damit die
rüstungsindustrie zu unterstützen das
wollen wir so nicht grundsätzlich müssen
wir aber auch feststellen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der linken
immer wenn krisen vorherrschen und eine
branche davon besonders profitiert dann
wollen sie auch ein stück vom kuchen
abhaben dass er selber haben sie im
vergangenen jahr durch die krone krise
auch schon versucht und bei unternehmen
wie zum beispiel nennen den namen bei
und
versucht ihr die über gewinne
abzuschöpfen jetzt muss man eines sagen
bei uns einen großen teil dieser über
gewinne in die forschung wieder gesteckt
um die impfstoffe zu verbessern um hier
weiterzukommen und das gleiche und das
gleiche das gebe ich ihnen jetzt mit
vorderstes von den erzeugern oder den
energieunternehmen denn wir wollen ja
alle dass wir unabhängiger werden vom
russischen gas unabhängiger werden von
russischem öl fordern sie die soll
forschen und entwickeln bei der nutzung
von erneuerbaren energien denn da wäre
dieses geld richtig gut aufgelegt wurden
aufgehoben und am ende der tage haben
auch die menschen was da von thomas mehr
hin und es sollten sie auffordern
[Applaus]
es mag zwar sein dass man mit dieser
zufalls gewinnsteuern in ihren augen für
mehr gerechtigkeit sorgt das wurde in
vielen reden heute schon gesagt es wird
nicht mehr gerechtigkeit sei er mehr
ungerechtigkeit
deshalb lassen wir die finger davon wir
sollten jetzt gekonnte und richtige
anreize setzen dass die unternehmen die
energieunternehmen sie freiwillig
unabhängig vom russischen öl und gas
wochen und den wandel hin zu
alternativen energieformen mit angehen
das können sie mal machen wenn man sagt
verwendet ein teil davon für forschung
und entwicklung bei alternativen
energien entlasten wir dann so wie sie
übrigens auch immer sorgen mit
alternativen energien könnte man die
verbraucher nehmen verbraucher entlasten
das ist der richtige weg diesen antrag
kann man mit voller überzeugung ablehnen
weil er nicht brauchbar ist dankeschön
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin melanie
wirklich für die spd fraktion
und auch melanie wegele sitzt im
finanzausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen plus 147
prozent für shell plus 190 prozent für
total plus zu 120 prozent für excel zu
extrem haben sich die gewinne einiger
energiekonzerne im ersten quartal diesen
jahres entwickelte eine der
hauptursachen dafür ist der
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
es handelt sich also um eine ausnahme
situation für die die energiekonzerne
und die märkte nicht direkt
verantwortlich sind ich halte es deshalb
für durchaus angemessen das wort
krisengewinner hier in diesem
zusammenhang zu verwenden es geht
es geht dabei gleichzeitig nicht darum
unternehmensgewinne an sich anzugreifen
oder anzuprangern angesichts der
krisenlage und der soeben erwähnten
zahlen es jedoch angebracht hier mal
genauer hinzuschauen da sind
energiekonzerne die wie alle anderen
unternehmen ihre gewinne für
investitionen nutzen können und das ist
ja auch richtig so wir würden daher
gezielte investitionen in erneuerbare
energien und in die dazu passen
infrastrukturen einfallen oder man
könnte sich angesichts der massiv
gestiegenen lebensunterhalts kosten um
spürbare lohnerhöhungen für die
beschäftigten gewinnen es sind jedoch
zweifel erlaubt ob die großen profiteure
des mineralölsektor eine dieser beiden
richtungen entschlossen einschlagen
werden oder doch eher die interessen der
aktionäre wahren wollen wie es der bp
chef selbst gesagt hat
auf der anderen seite sind da aber eben
auch die menschen die die steigenden
energie grab energiepreise schmerzhaft
spüren der auf sein auto im alltag und
im beruf angewiesen ist muss die über
die spritpreise zahlen und finanziert
hierdurch die besagten über gewinne der
in die unternehmen so schlägt vor allem
bei gering und normalverdienern auf aber
auch beim start der entlastungspaket
gespürt eine auseinandersetzung mit der
frage der verteilungsgerechtigkeit finde
ich an dieser stelle durchaus angemessen
die aktuellen krisen belasten sicherlich
auch mineralölkonzerne erhöhte
rohölpreise logistik sowie
transportkosten wurde auch teure
anpassungen an die geopolitischen
gegebenheiten aber die wirklich riesigen
gewinn zu wechseln lassen aufhorchen vom
kleinen handwerksbetrieb bei mir um die
ecke habe ich noch nicht gehört dass der
preisaufschläge durchdrücken kann die im
gewinn zuschüsse von 190 prozent
einbrechen meine älteren bietet trotz
gestiegener weiteren kosten ihre
brötchen auch nicht für aberwitzige
preise an um damit zwei
hundertprozentige gewinnanstiege zu
erzielen es handelt sich also
letztendlich auch um eine frage des
anstands gegenüber der gesellschaft in
einer ausnahmesituation sowie um eine
frage von gerechter umverteilungspolitik
das kann man aus meiner sicht bei diesem
thema gerne diskutieren wenngleich auch
meine vorrednerin die technischen mängel
des antrages bereits dargestellt haben
ich freue mich deshalb auf die weiteren
beratungen im finanzausschuss vielen
dank
[Applaus]